[Music]
it's my honor to introduce first lady
Michelle Obama what's going on you guys
just hang it out a little bit huh
listening a little music
this happens every night here right well
let me just say officially hello Al
Udeid I'd like to invite my friend one
of your biggest fans to the stage the
one and only Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
the first lady has left the building are
you ready for a show
I'm really not I'm so happy first of all
to see your faces I'm also so happy I've
been living on the base now for 24 hours
a lot of people don't know that they
offered me a room at the st. Regis and I
said no I want to live on the base
that's what I said because I'm an idiot
have you seen the st. Regis welcome to
Memorial Plaza come on Who am I kidding
no one calls it that we're at the bra
it's the bra what amateur name you came
up with I'm standing under this
Southwest nipple right now you know why
I knew it was called the bra because it
took me 45 minutes of fumbling to get
inside this morning I walked out of my
barracks when I got completely lost and
I asked someone I'm trying to find the
place where you go to get food
independence I'm trying to find I think
it's called independence or freedom or
victory food or strength through carbs
or whatever and I said I want to find
that building and they said it's easy
it's the beige building surrounded by
gravel you can't miss it
there's not even a tree like go to the
old maple tree and take there's no tree
you have a gazebo and someone painted it
military beige I know you guys the
military loved your acronyms they're
hard to all these letters you don't use
real words everything's a letter you
know everything's three letters four
letters and you got to try and figure
out what the hell you're talking about
but I did some research I know how to
talk to you guys now you men you women
I'm right now I'm AWOL from TBS for R&R
and I am DTF
[Applause]
the doorknob
or fellas I don't care at this point